Prendre l'avion avec toutes les règles de sécurité
qu'il y a maintenant, c'est vraiment un plaisir.
Faux !
Déjà, quand on va
sur le site d'Air France,
on peut voir la liste des différents trucs
qu'on n'a pas le droit de prendre dans l'avion.
Alors, bagages en cabine.
Marchandises interdites :
les armes blanches,
les armes à feu,
les cartouches et munitions pour armes,
les cartouches d'imprimante.
Les cartouches d'imprimante ?
Il y a plein de terroristes qui terrorisent
avec des cartouches d'imprimante.
Personne ne bouge !
J'ai une cartouche d'imprimante !
OK ?
>> Les mecs, faites ce qu'il vous dit.
Sinon, il va nous jeter de l'encre.
On n'a pas le droit non plus d'emporter dans
notre bagage à main des bouteilles de plus d'un litre.
Et heureusement, à l'aéroport,
quand l'agent de sécurité te le dit,
il te propose quand même deux choix.
Alors soit vous la jetez
à la poubelle maintenant,
ou alors vous la buvez
entièrement maintenant.
Comment ça ?
Écoutez, c'est pas parce que
j'ai les lunettes de Richard Virac,
qu'il ne faut pas me prendre
au sérieux, OK ?
Un vrai plaisir.
C'est bon.
Les mecs
qui vomissent dans l'avion,
c'est pas parce qu'ils ont le mal de l'air,
c'est parce qu'ils sont bourrés.
Ils ont bu toutes les bouteilles.
C'est le règlement.
Dans la famille des règles débiles,
il est strictement interdit,
attention, d'écouter
un MP3 au décollage.
En quoi ça peut faire
crasher l'avion ?
OK, tour de contrôle, on est prêt dans la cabine.
Décollage dans quelques minutes.
Attendez,
quelqu'un a lancé un MP3.
Houlà !
Il se passe quoi, là ?
Je crois que c'est
le dernier tube de M.Pokora.
On va se crasher !
♪ S'en aller plus haut ♪
Pourquoi les stewards, avant le décollage,
sont toujours obligés de nous faire flipper,
en nous rappelant qu'il y a peut-être
un risque qu'on meurt pendant le vol ?
Nous vous rappelons qu'il y a quand même
un risque que la cabine se dépressurise.
Auquel cas, pendant un instant, vous allez
être très, très mal, vous n'arrivez plus à respirer,
mais heureusement, il y a des masques
à gaz qui vont tomber sur votre visage.
Nous tenons à vous rappeler qu'il y a une chance
pour que l'avion finisse au milieu de l'océan.
Plouf !
Et heureusement,
il y a des gilets de sauvetage,
qui pourront nous aider
à flotter au milieu du Pacifique,
dans une flaque de carburant inflammable
pendant plusieurs jours.
Nous vous rappelons également
que nous pouvons à tout moment
tomber ou perdre une aile.
À cet instant, nous allons tous partir
en couille dans tous les sens.
Certains vont perdre
des membres de leur famille.
Mais ne paniquez pas
et suivez les petites lumières
situées au sol dans le couloir.
Franchement,
ce speech des stewards,
je comprends pas pourquoi
ils continuent à le faire.
Parce que ça saoule
tous les passagers.
On peut juste un truc :
décoller !
Eux-mêmes, quand ils le font, on dirait
qu'ils sont saoulés de le répéter tout le temps.
Sur les côtés, devant
et derrière la cabine.
En ce qui concerne les gilets,
si jamais l'avion crashe—
Oh putain, ce boulot me fait chier !
Moi, perso, pour être
en panique totale dans l'avion,
j'ai pas besoin qu'il tombe.
Il me suffit juste de cette indication :
Zone de turbulences
Aaaaahhh !
La panique intégrale !
Même à 300 km/h
au-dessus des nuages,
il y a encore des mecs
qui passent dans les couloirs,
pour essayer de te vendre
des trucs à la sauvette.
Ça s'appelle le "duty-free".
Ce qui est ouf, c'est qu'ils arrivent à te vendre
des objets qui n'ont aucun rapport entre eux.
Est-ce que quelqu'un veut
des cigarettes ou du parfum ?
Une boîte de clous ?
Une place de concert ?
Un caleçon Monoprix ?
Un poireau ?
Une bombe anti-moustiques
ayant appartenu à Elvis Presley ?
Et puis, un parfum qui vient de l'avion,
je ne sais pas si c'est ce qu'il y a de plus classe.
Hmm, tu sens bon, tu l'as eu où ton parfum ?
>> Dans l'avion.
À moitié prix.
Jean-Paul Dutyfree.
C'est moins cher,
mais chut !
Y a au moins un truc cool
quand tu prends l'avion.
C'est que tu peux sortir
cette phrase un peu classe :
Mmh.
Je suis jetlagué,
je reviens d'un vol pour New York,
je suis jetlagué de huit heures.
Là, dans ma tête, je suis en train
de me réveiller en plein Times Square.
Bon, évidemment, ça marche pas si tu as pris
un vol pour faire Paris-La Rochelle.
Voilà, je reviens d'un vol, j'étais à la Rochelle.
Je suis jetlagué de six minutes.
La prochaine fois
que je prendrais l'avion,
je le prendrai un peu
plus long, comme ça,
avec des longs compartiments
et des rails sur le sol.